What do "Game of Thrones" and "Gladiator" have in common?
Both were filmed in this Moroccan desert.
It's no secret some of our favorite films and TV shows...
...aren't exactly filmed on the location we'd expect,...
...but Atlas Studios in Morocco...
...might have some of the most diverse variety of locations...
...within its studio walls.
In just steps, you can go from feeling like...
...you're in ancient Egypt to a medieval castle to a Buddhist temple.
The area has always been a popular choice for Hollywood,...
...starting with Lawrence of Arabia in 1962.
Since then, it's been used for films such as the live action Aladdin,...
...The Mummy and Gladiator,...
...and TV shows such as Game of Thrones, Atlantis and Prison Break.
The studio is one of the largest in the world at over 300,000 square feet.
Its popularity stems from its reliable climate...
...that can mimic a variety of countries.
Tourists are welcome to visit the site,...
...but it will be an adventure of your own making,...
...as Atlas Studio is still used as an active film set.
However, you can schedule a guided tour to hear all about the set secret.